Tom McShea
I love raiding tombs in fact this time
last year I spent a large portion of my
time reading tombs but apparently
there's a definitive way I know to raid
tombs and I think and it's just comment
yeah officially although apparently got
leaked a bit I love it
so tell me Tomb Raider definitive
edition on the ps4 and Xbox one if I've
played Tomb Raider already why should I
play this
I have you played all a tomb raider I
complete the term rated so I didn't play
much multiplayer though you're in luck
okay
the finem edition has more mats ok and
multiplayer skins for people like you
who do not care about the multi players
though it also has like a new outfit for
Laura choice in this single-player Lara
Croft I should say and it has one new -
ok one these are the optional slightly
questi - - so that as all the DLC except
for like a character specific xbox360
character ok it's the only thing you're
not going to get so it has all that
stuff but really it's it's the same game
because nobody cares all the multiplayer
and like Lara skins doesn't really
change much so the Xbox 360 and
PlayStation 3 versions that came out
last year they looked great on yeah idea
and then a couple of months ago we had
the PC version came out we've had all
the Tres effects and all that stuff so
graphically is there is there much of
other reason to buy this on a next-gen
console it looks gorgeous it's by the
best looking game that I've seen in the
next-gen console - no no it's it's it's
it's a game that already already looked
gorgeous like yeah it's yeah there's
more polygons and I guess there's a Anti
of one of the terms bit mapping sure I'm
it masher so stuff like that but it's
like it's not gonna French if you have
that efficiently change your experience
like is it's a great looking game
regardless so umm it's weird cuz I
absolutely love this game and I just
have yeah I can't recommend the
definitive edition if you played last
year's game is it not is it not one of
those games that's kind of inherently
for maybe to replay oh like that's the
thing yeah it is the thing because I
love replaying it and everybody comes to
my desk like I played it last year but I
want to play it again yeah so I just
kind of liked that but it's like do you
want to sell it shell on another 60
bucks for that uh well there's nothing
else to buy in the Xbox one I guess
you gotta justify it somehow I know it's
not is it's wholly the game that
everybody needs to play yeah everybody
needs to play it one of the five
versions of Tomb Raider hmm and I don't
really care which one you play because
you're going to have the same basic
experience no matter where you are is
there anything in terms of the Xbox one
on PlayStation 4 is like functionality
outside of the game that might it make
it better like in terms of the
technology that's in those consoles does
it change at all good question so it
looks better on the ps4 better prime
rate probably better textures and stuff
but it looks it looks slightly better on
the ps4 so if you want the best graphics
that's the one both of them if you plug
in their cameras kinect and PSI
respectively there's voice commands oh
really which i didn't ask for this
nobody but if you say map or if for
instance sean McKenna's wants to grief
you and say map when you're playing a
map will appear great or you can hit a
button finally for a map is that the
only voice come on now you can switch
weapons you can switch my shotgun it's
like I can hit like if you really like
that stuff it totally works perfectly
can you shout a gratuitous death scene
and it just spawns one of largets pulls
your head oh my god anywhere in the game
nothing will top in Halo I never sue -
we could change the resolution by
speaking know it is the best movie can
you do that in to read a definitive
edition that's a damn shame
that's yeah I mean this it's it's kind
of weird $60 if you only get to be a $40
game but whatever it's awesome
what about so what about folks who own
an Xbox one on the PlayStation 4 have
never played Tomb Raider do you think
this is one of the games that they
probably should all understand hundred
percent like I know what are you doing
if you don't why do you own the system
if you're not gonna play - right because
it's a great showcase for like what they
could do visually and it's just super
fun awesome thanks very much your time
Tom thank you anyone who wants to pick
up Tomb Raider definitive edition it's
available in the stores right now
you